there is a woman an inspiration to us  all she's suing craft  you know the makers of the mac and  cheese she's suing craft for five  million dollars and she is suing them  because Velveeta ready Mac takes more  than three and a half minutes to cook  if you've ever purchased a delicious  Velveeta ready Mac you'll know it says  eat your ready Mac in only three and a  half minutes but this woman has found  out it actually takes more than that  because you got to open the package and  you've got to pour the water in then you  put it in the microwave then you let it  sit a little bit then you put the the  powder in and then you stir it you maybe  let it cool a little bit so  it takes I don't know four minutes or  something but it's it's more and so  she's suing craft for five million  dollars over this  the uh the lawyer who is bringing this  case said look I know some people think  it's frivolous but this is false  advertising okay we've got to go we're  going to take them to court